hey youtubers is Charlie so we just got
some news about Kevin Lannister in Game
of Thrones season 5 so I thought I'd do
a history video for him there's also a
new wildling character that they
revealed is gonna be at hardhome i'll
explain who that is we saw him in the
trailer briefly I know a lot of you guys
are asking about the george RR martin
initial Game of Thrones draft so I'll
try to explain that too it's really just
like a simpler version of what he ended
up doing first things first though Kevan
Lannister okay so here we go just
careful for spoilers through season 4 on
the show so Kevan Lannister has only
appeared in seasons 1 & 2 of Game of
Thrones so far of the TV series the
reason why people think he's gonna be in
season 5 is because the actor that plays
him was seen on set near the end of
their production cycle he has a really
big part in feast for crows and dance of
dragons if you have read those books
just please use spoiler tags in the
comments if you want to comment about
him I think the show will do his book
plot but they'll only do the big stuff
we just won't see him on screen all the
time that's one of the downfalls of the
show it has to pick and choose the
characters that it focuses on so you
lose a lot of the really small moments
from the side characters the fun part is
is the Kevin transitions from a
background character to a main character
almost although I don't know if the
show's gonna depict him that way after
Tywin's death in season 4 he is the next
lannister in line
aside from Thailand's children to take
over a Casterly Rock technically the
succession would float to Jaime but
since he's a white cloak he can't
inherit property nor does it seem like
he wants to and Circe's a woman so she's
also out of the running too bad they
weren't born in Dorne Doran tends to
honor its women much more than the rest
of Westeros think of it as being very
progressive King's Landing not so much
Kevin is also Lancel father remember the
last time we saw him he was given it to
Cersei kevin is a lot like Tywin
Lannister very practical very driven
during the war of the five kings he was
actually one of tywin's chief counsel
unlike Tywin in the rest of the
Lannisters he actually still has quite a
bit of money if you remember before he
died
Tywin implied that the gold mines the
Lannisters gold mines were starting to
run dry the crown is severely in debt so
Kevin is just one of those people that
could potentially help them out he's one
of the closest family members who you
gonna run to when you need money well
you're gonna run to your family first
even though Kevin spent a lot of his
life in Tywin shado
I don't think that he's super jealous
where things sit right now he's actually
in a pretty good place as a family man
he's a little
open about his emotions than Tywin is
when he finds out about the siege of
King's Landing he actually starts to
freak out a little bit about his son
Lancel it makes you think of that scene
at the beginning of season 4 when
Jamie's meeting with Tywin right after
getting his golden hand when Tywin tries
to give him the new Valyrian sword that
was reforged out of ice to be fair
though I'm not sure Tywin being a more
loving father to Jaime and Cersei would
have altered any of their weird twincest
choices or what followed Tywin still
probably would have tried to marry
Cersei to Robert Baratheon Jaime still
would've ended up in the white cloaks
that's one of the things I like most
about Song of Ice and Fire is that bad
things happen to good and bad characters
it doesn't matter if you're evil I think
what's gonna be most interesting is to
see how all the characters are changed
based on the crazy stuff that happened
last season especially Tywin's death and
King's Landing
does anybody else kind of wonder if
they're gonna dovetail Kevin's story
with Jamie's story in season 5 if
they're changing Jamie's story
significantly from the books if he's
going to a dramatically different place
does that mean that Kevin's story will
also tie in with that it's definitely
gonna be fun having a character in
King's Landing that isn't gonna take
from anyone that's like the high
Sparrow character characters that are
just like this is bullcrap I'm calling
you on it I was like how George R Martin
has these ridiculous characters that go
on these big tirades and then there's
always someone that will step in and
call them on their at some
point there's always some other
character waiting to slap them to their
senses for those that have read book 5
yes I do feel like a lot of what Kevin
does in book 5 is gonna get cut out if
you haven't read it don't worry it's not
a big deal you're not gonna miss it it
has a lot to do with the young Griff
storyline just in things to look forward
to from Kevin he has a lot of money the
ability to hire mercenaries if he needs
them to raise an army which most other
people in Westeros don't have right now
and he's really quick to call people on
their I'm really looking
forward to some unlikable characters
being put in their place so here's my
big question for you guys even if you
haven't read the books remember Kevin
lannister Tywin's younger brother what
do you want to see him do in season 5 if
you have read the books feel free to
include a book moment but just please
use a spoiler tag just to explain that
new wildling character supposedly his
name is loboda
he'll be one of the wildling leaders at
hardhome he's not specifically a
character from the books but he might
end up getting a lot of scenes with Jon
Snow and just a comment on the George
are Martin modified Game of Thrones
story the info that was posted is just
an initial
line for the series there are some
interesting differences so vastly fewer
storylines mostly focusing on the
Lannisters in the starts a lot of the
big stuff is still there like a lot of
the same characters still ended up dying
Robert Baratheon red wedding stuff still
happened one of the big differences
though is the way Daenerys got her
dragons instead of being a wedding gift
she just finds them during a Dothraki
invasion that she leads he also does a
lot more with the battles they're like
there's like a lot more attention paid
to what happens during the battles
really I think the original structure is
just more traditional fantasy like what
you see from most fantasy books since
they've been published a lot of people
have been really happy with the way
Martin has structured his story just
because it's been such a departure from
talking and anytime someone writes a new
fantasy story everyone always talks
about how it looks like Lord of the
Rings or some other familiar really big
series Martin's is a good example of
something that's really different so
anytime you have a friend who's looking
to read fantasy but doesn't like Lord of
the Rings and want something really
different Game of Thrones is the perfect
example or A Song of Ice and Fire so as
much as it turned into this big
sprawling thing and it's made it a lot
harder to get books out faster it's also
made it that much better
I think it all has a lot to do with why
the series is so popular one of the
really cool detail is that Martin talks
about how he doesn't like to make
outlines so he doesn't like to plan his
stories out too much in advance I feel
like he does have a really good idea
where he wants the rest of the series to
go he knows like the big signpost that
he wants to get to it's just like all
the side stories all the lesser
characters that he plans out while he's
doing it he's really good about posting
sample chapters like wins a winner for
instance he posts a lot of sample bits
of that throughout the year so he might
update that pretty soon the last sample
he posted was for an area and Martel
chapter so it's the new Game of Thrones
video so I need to announce a new winner
of the giveaway congratulations to
Edward Brock you'd actually get your
pick you can pick the Amazon giftcard
it's just a $20 Amazon gift card or you
can pick a copy of the game of Thrones
telltale game just be sure to message me
on my channel for contact details so I
get your email don't worry I will do a
new round of the giveaway whenever I do
my behind-the-scenes video for those
asking about the telltale Game episode 2
is released this week I am gonna do some
gameplay videos on my game channel so if
you don't know where that is it's
Charlie's dreams there's a link in the
description I'm gonna try and stream on
my twitch channel on Saturday okay so
don't forget this weekend I'll be
posting my game
roans behind-the-scenes video on Sunday
after HBO airs the special on TV be sure
to subscribe to get that it'll feel like
a full-on episode it won't be like the 7
minute special that they did last year
it'll be way bigger than that so while
you guys wait for that you can click
here to watch the season 5 trailer again
and you can click here to watch the
daredevil Netflix trailer it'll be like
the closest we ever get to a Marvel HBO
series it's gonna be pretty graphic way
more graphic from the stuff on ABC so
thank you so much for watching so it's
all high-five I'll see you guys this
weekend
[Music]